we have music and Christmastime I know
you are 98 degrees fan and totally Shay
and they've got an early Christmas
present for everyone a new tour and I
was exclusively at the rehearsal take a
look I mean we're doing what seven hours
a day rehearsal something like that no
90 degrees you know our choreography is
grueling
yeah that's intense
[Music]
the older we get the slower we learn
we're actually working longer now than
we ever had well there be Christmas
presents and given out during this tour
Oh
besides the gift of music yeah the music
is present enough I mean that's the gift
that just keeps on giving for the next
seven weeks these guys will be giving
that gift to fans performing 36 shows
across the country on the set list all
those 90 songs that made us and
Christmas classics from their holiday
album let it snow this now this album is
your second Christmas album it is the
first one was way back in the 90s but
this album cover is so much better than
the first one yes
the first one was just God we all look
kind of jaundiced yeah and basically and
now we look healthy it's like ha ha ha
Christmas time on the back he like still
sexy 90 degrees that's Christmas night
going out on the town
what is this song when you're on tour
that the fans go the craziest for I
think I do because I feel like it has a
lot more long-lasting effect in people's
lives a lot of people got married to it
people made out with your boyfriend how
do you keep the 90s girls at bay what
we've found is as we've all gotten older
yeah now our fans are just trying to
find the bar which is interesting
because it's usually where listen drew
and Nick your daddies now but you know
what daddy can be sexy by the way the
band's tour kicks off tonight in
Winnipeg and they also have their
greatest hits album called the
collection which is out right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]